peace y'all what up it's your man king
crooked check me out on the bootleg care
podcast you feel me salute
we have a special guest on the boulet
kev show today
a legend one of the greatest rappers to
ever touch a microphone thank you man i
appreciate that we talk about lyricism
when we talk about
at any given time this guy could be
considered the best rapper alive when
he's just in his pocket man i appreciate
that bro crooked eye
what up what you kev man
would you consider yourself one of the
most underrated rappers of all time as
well you know well i feel like i
underrate you sometimes because when
people ask me that question i always go
to like black thought or sean price i'd
be like
you're one of those guys too i mean
m
had posted that in his opinion i was the
most underrated in hip-hop history
that's amc
you know what i'm saying and um a lot of
people feel that way um
uh
where who it depends on who's doing the
rating
you feel me so
if you know you know if you know if you
know no no there's a lot of goat
contenders you know i mean who don't get
on songs with me
yeah i mean listen i just think when it
comes to like word play lyrics i mean
the things that make an mcn mc i just i
think that at when you're in your bag
it's rough i mean there ain't a lot of
people who can hang with you man hey i
appreciate that i mean that's that's
years that's years that's huge man it's
crazy too because i just remember back
in the day
buying the swaying king tech albums from
like the liquor store
and that is where i first discovered you
from those freestyles because they used
to have like the best of the wake up
show
and this might have been around the time
you're on death row or it might have
been before but
that was like kind of
you know i mean how many years ago was
that man i was a kid so that was that
was years i was a kid too i mean
that was in the 90s probably somewhere
yeah you know what i mean
shout out to swan tech because they
always so i heard tech nine for the
first time too yeah they they have their
platform
they really shared their platform with
real lyrics you know and when their
platform was at its height you know
um
syndication and you know they're on one
of the biggest stations in america they
were letting people come up there and
drop straight bars i hope that we get a
a documentary
for them in the same way we got a
stretch and bobido uh documentary
because i feel like what they did was
like
equals equally as important for guys
like eminem for guys like all these you
know we could go on and on yeah i mean
that's the first time i ever heard
eminem was on swintech facts
well listen uh welcome to the show
obviously
so much we got to talk about yeah so
much we got to unpack it's litty um
you got an album coming out with with
joelle yes sir tomorrow night
uh
this is an album that has obviously
stirred up a lot of uh controversy it
stirred up a lot of opinions right uh
the records that you guys have put out
have been great so far for people who
are unaware this is the second time you
and joel have put out a joint project
absolutely um
so let's get let's get first of all who
like like the initial idea
of
theming this album around the rise and
fall slaughterhouse right
where did the idea come from and
how long
have you guys been working on this body
of work um basically
man you know i had an opportunity for
the whole group
slaughterhouse
and um you know
let's give us the timeline how long ago
was that this was in august okay august
of 2021 august of 2021 i had an
opportunity
i felt it was a good opportunity for
where slaughterhouse is today you know i
mean um
we kind of dropped off the scene as the
streaming
um era took off
you know what i mean our last album was
in 2012. this is that's 10 years ago
wow that's so great i'm [ __ ] old man
yeah dawg that's what i'm saying you
know what i was saying like
so
our fans have been glass house
no
the glass house never came out no that's
right that was the that was
that was the welcome to our house with
the ceelo single and all that yes sir so
that was 10 years ago and our fans have
been waiting on music for 10 years you
know what i'm saying so
i had this opportunity i thought it was
a great opportunity um
i spoke to a couple other guys about it
and
it was brought back to me that joe
didn't think that that was a good
opportunity you know i mean he didn't
want to do it so
joe didn't want to do it and roy said he
didn't want to do it if joe joe wasn't
doing it now maybe maybe royce felt like
it it
it's not really slaughterhouse unless
it's all four
you know what i mean because
and and so it might not just be because
of joe per se it could have just been
whatever but i went back to the label
and i was like yo
what could you offer us for just us
three you know what i mean because joe
is retired and he's he doesn't seem
interested in this deal right here
um and they were like yo we rock and
roll with you let's do it you know and
um
so when i brought that to royce he was
like nah
you know
slaughterhouse needs to be all four of
us so um
when we hung up the phone
me him and joelle me and joelle got back
on the phone the next day and was like
yo
i was like yo how'd you feel about that
conversation
and he said it felt like the group was
officially over and i said yeah it does
you know it's been 10 years
we bring the opportunity to the table
you know they don't want to do it you
know um for whatever reason you know
they're entitled of course to to to you
know want to do business or not um
i was like man
this [ __ ] is pretty pretty much over so
you know we sat on it for a minute
and then i called joelle back and i was
like yo man let's get back in there
he was like yeah man let's get back in
there and do something
and it was just a conversation what are
we going to talk about and i was like
man let's talk about
all the [ __ ] that happened
in slaughterhouse let's talk about the
good times the bad times let's just
let's give the fans some closure you
know what i'm saying and and let's give
ourselves some therapy you know and uh
that's how the whole concept started
rolling out and this was in like
i would say
probably after september so something
like that
october
so the other day the ig live happens
with joe and royce and then joelle comes
up on you were on a flight right yeah i
was on the flight you were in the air
you probably would have been on there as
well right i tried to get in there
though i would even i would even gather
to say that that conversation
would have probably been a lot more
measured if you were a part of it
because i feel like you're
you're kind of i i just know you yeah um
now
there were certain aspects of that
conversation where i could kind of see
everyone's perspective right
um
when we when we think of like
like did you guys ever actually hear joe
say no or was it like some hearsay
because he said he never turned down the
deal and the thing that royce kept
bringing out was when did we when did we
say no over and over and over and then
there was just a lot of back and forth
royce is calling joelle liar joel's
calling them like why are y'all lying
what like is there any
chance that there was
muddled communication or there was
because i mean all four of you guys from
what i know are stand-up guys who would
not lie on each other yeah there's no
reason to lie i think that
can you kind of give me some context on
where some of the you're a liar why the
[ __ ] are you lying well you're lying
when did i turn it down like that is
kind of where it's like to me it's like
okay
there's a huge disconnect on yeah each
side of what actually happened right and
it's it's
i feel like
to be honest they were kind of put in a
position
who's that joe and royce okay they
didn't know
that this album was coming out
so
i kind of afforded them
you know
a little elbow room
to be emotional
and
you know
try to address it in the best way that
they could being caught off guard like
that
you know what i'm saying um
now
within that i'm trying to say that you
know
maybe that's the reason that the story
doesn't add up
you see i'm saying because it's like yo
what are we gonna say
you feel me but
point blank no fat no no opinions no no
lies no
just straight facts
i brought the deal to the table okay
i told the guys i need to get on a phone
call with all of them
i couldn't get in contact with joe
because joe said he never actually saw a
deal right joe never called me so
so
i got on twitter
and i said hey guys because i talked to
my
supporters you're very active on twitter
on twitter very much 100 so i'll say hey
guys
i didn't tell them about the deal i'm
just like yo y'all want to see the gang
back together i'm giving everybody 48
hours to call me
okay
48 hours went by royce hit me yo what's
going on that's when i say yo this is
what's going on i got this deal it's
it's a great opportunity for us there's
ownership involved you know we're going
to be able to do our thing roll it out
how we want to roll it out everything is
laid out
you know we good all right we just need
to all get on the phone so
he calls joe
all right so joe
i don't want to do it
okay
joe calls joelle man what's crook doing
on twitter
he got everybody in my telling me to
call him yeah right right right
well he got this deal joe and yada yada
well i don't want to do the deal and i
don't want to be the one to [ __ ] on
crook right now about this deal so i'm
gonna call i'm gonna think about it but
i'm gonna call crook in a couple hours
and then this was relayed to you from
royce from
from joelle
told me that to expect a call from joe
in an hour okay
and he was going to tell me why he
didn't want to do the deal
assuming you never got the call never
got the call
royce called me a couple of times i
remember like it was yesterday i was
getting a cover test because i was going
to hawaii
i was at the airport
and he said yo so joe said
he don't think that's a good deal
you know the thing the the
the deal memo points that i kind of
conveyed to race race told joe so
essentially the advance amount yeah all
that [ __ ] advance about it
percentages whatever
so i said well
i tell you what royce
tell joe to call me
we all get on the phone and whatever joe
wants
we'll give it to him
because i got juice like that with the
people that i'm working with for people
so we have full contacts who are the
people that offer the deal
well
one of my business partners has
distribution through every major that
there is okay and he's a business
partner of mine outside of music too
and i've been doing business with him
he's like a brother to me
so this guy
was in a position where he wanted to
bankroll the situation
he could bankroll it
he could if you just wanted to bankroll
it yourself
you know you could just use the whatever
so he had but he was gonna bankroll it
so based on what what those deal points
were
joe was joe said he didn't want to do it
okay
and i told royce to give me a call i can
get joe whatever he wants to get put
into the paperwork but i'm not going to
go back and forth and you know with the
attorneys and let's see this and let's
see this just tell me what you want
we've all been in the game past 20
something years we know what contracts
look like tell me exactly what you want
we'll put it in the contract and then
we'll start from there we'll start from
what you want john wherever you want you
know i mean and i was doing that
honestly as a courtesy to royce because
i got love for royce you know i mean i
already was at a point where this was my
last time ever trying to do business
with joe button again so i got love for
roy so i said you know what as a
courtesy
we'll do that you know what i mean to
try to see
if we can get the fans this this this
last album so
you know he's like all right man y'all
got to talk about it i'm i'm like yeah
because he's he he's being the middle
man
joe was using royce as a middleman to
con to communicate with me i didn't like
that because joe because royce is a
general
and i start feeling like why is he
trying to use this man as a foot soldier
you know what i'm saying this dude is a
general all men are created equal we all
should be on the phone together it's no
reason you shouldn't be calling me right
now so he didn't call he never called
weeks went by months went by and it was
like everybody just went back to their
corners and i never even heard back
about the deal did you know none of that
stuff it was just over man so
you know
um and once roy said it he didn't want
to do it as a three-man crew which he's
totally entitled to right once he said
that it was like all right well
this [ __ ] is over
you know what i'm saying is
i don't think
i don't think that what i could have
communicated better to royce because
as a friend
i could have communicated it better to
him that
i'm only talking to joe for you
hmm
i i would prefer to move slaughterhouse
forward without joe because joe is
retired and there's been a lot of snags
dealing with joe in the business side of
things so i would rather move
slaughterhouse forward without joe but
as a courtesy to my friend
and i know you [ __ ] with joe and i know
you have a different relationship with
joe yeah that's fine bring joe to the
table but i don't think that
as a friend i don't think that i
communicated that
enough he knows where i'm at
but i feel like he felt like he could
massage the situation crook got love for
me joe got love for me i could probably
be the glue to to keep all that [ __ ]
together you know what i mean but he
didn't know that i was at my
last final breaking point with joe or
joe as far as the slaughterhouse
situation goes now you had said that
to be fair
joe and royce did not know this album
was coming
yeah they didn't know
can you take uh
any responsibility in keeping them in
the loop or did you not feel like you
needed to because this was not a
slaughterhouse album it's not a
slaughterhouse album i'm not kept in the
loop with none of their albums that
they're dropping and to be honest with
you it was a situation where i said you
know what we need to tell our story and
we don't need
any distractions we need to go maybe if
you give them the heads up
the distractions start coming from
behind the scenes and you guys aren't
able to focus on
the task absolutely
there's no way we had to take that
energy
when we got off the phone that
heartbreak that heartbreak that energy
that we had
that this [ __ ] is over
we had to take that into the into the
booth
that had to go into the booth that was
the energy that needed to go into the
booth to create this for the fans you
know what i mean and
all
we talk so much like willie d say no
more talk
we talked so much it got to the for ten
[ __ ] years ten years it got to the
point where talking
and no actions was just
i had it up to here man i couldn't i
couldn't talk i couldn't talk one more
time i mean you're at your west end with
the with the slaughterhouse situation in
general and i'm sure fans feel the same
way i mean listen you guys have a core
fan base that is there right but i do
feel like over time the fan base
the excitement for a new slaughterhouse
almost getting smaller and smaller and
smaller because it's just been so long
10
years brother
like think about that put yourself in
the fans um shoes for two seconds and i
don't think this is what the group ever
did
i don't think they really
specifically what joe and royce are
saying i don't watch everything that
they say because i'm not about to
um
fall into that type of a trap and that
that low vibration energy and you know
calling names and you know liars and all
this type of [ __ ] i'm i'm not even
trying to fall into none of that but
people send me clips people tell me hey
this this this is what happened in all
this
you know put put yourself in the fan put
yourself in the fan shoes for a minute
you've been waiting on one of your
favorite groups in the world to drop an
album for 10 years
now behind the scenes i've been taking
flights to new york go talk to paul
rosenberg i've been taking flights to
detroit talking to him talking to d uh
to rice how can we put this back
together you know what i mean and
it's it's not happened in 10 years
so it's like you know what you're
telling me you want me
to wait again and then i saw something
where roy said that we weren't waiting
on anybody that that's a lie
so i need to address all this stuff
because
whenever they say that i just come back
with the truth you know what i'm saying
like you you can attack my character my
integrity you could try to assassinate
it and say that i'm a liar and i'm doing
this for money and all this other type
of [ __ ] but i'm gonna just keep on
hitting back with truth we've we started
off slaughterhouse in the early days
waiting on joe
you know what i'm saying like when we
first got our deal with shady
we had a song called session one
on on one of m's projects
he was trying to you know put the group
on one of his projects i think it was
gonna be a bonus cut or something on one
of the albums and you know we're new to
the label let me
share my platform with the group right
so we do session one
and all the slaughterhouse fans know
joe budden isn't on session one well why
isn't jones session one
joe was signed to another label he was
caught up in some paperwork was it e1 at
the time or something he was signed to
amalgam digital okay okay
okay
and
they
called over to shady like hey we have
him under contract you have to get a
clearance from us to have him appear on
that song
right
so we're like wait a minute because all
of us
went in as supposedly free agents to
sign this deal with shady
and come to find out joe was on the
paperwork he said that they forged his
signature and that wasn't him and
the group was put on the shelf for a
minute while he was
fighting amalgam digital in court
um and we were waiting on joe
because we couldn't move forward now
here we are with a brand new deal with
shady records
and we can't even really move forward as
a group because we gotta wait on joe in
court and that took months let me tell
you that took months right so after the
um
the signature expert determined that
that was his signature on the on the
contract
we was able to figure out how you know
tomorrow
after that you know what i mean and
um that was that was the first time
waiting on joe to give the fan
slaughterhouse
a lot of other
scenarios like that
kept happening
you feel me so job-related scenarios joe
related scenarios where we're waiting on
joe
okay so when when roy says we don't wait
on joe it's like wait a minute what
about when we were
glass house was sitting around
collecting dust and we were all on a
conference call with paul rosenberg and
all of the shady staff and we said hey
guys when we gonna get back together to
do the album and we like okay let's
finish the album in the summer and joe's
like nah we can't do the summer
you know i gotta throw pool parties and
[ __ ] and i gotta do this other [ __ ] and
all that it's like okay so
we'll wait on that um we'll we'll
reconvene in september or october hit
him up september october no i still
ain't ready
waiting on joe so everybody was on the
same page to finish glass house except
joe for a while for a while
you know what i'm saying royce's studio
was always open see royce i feel he's
always down to work
if everybody is on board but if
everybody's not on board he's gonna do
his own thing which makes sense you feel
me yeah i mean that's that's just
logical um
it was always us waiting on joe to be on
board
and when i brought this last and final
opportunity to the table
and you telling me that i gotta wait on
joe
joe doesn't like it he wants to do some
other kind of deal well what kind of
deal does joe want to do because all of
a sudden
there's deals that he wants to do but
for 10 years there's been nothing it's
been crickets but now that i have this
now he wants to do another kind of deal
and it's like okay what kind of deal
does he want to do he wants to finance
it that's what i heard them talking
about when i did catch a piece of the
live they want to he wanted to finance
it he's like yo
it takes a lot of trust to go into that
type of business with somebody
you know i'm saying you got to have
like
if i was to i
if we would have to all for financing
one
it could never be just one person one
person and that one person could
definitely not be mr chopin i'm sorry
you know he don't have that type of
credit with me
when it comes to the business you know
what i'm saying now i'm just speaking on
slaughterhouse business he doesn't have
the credit with me
for me to say oh yeah cool you can
finance it joe um that's not gonna work
so
um i don't know whatever kind of deal
that they envisioned for the group
it wasn't gonna work with me anyway so
we come to a stalemate i'm not he don't
want to do the deal i'm bringing and i'm
not doing the deal his way so
it all leads to slaughterhouse being
over i think i think too what a lot of
people got to understand is like um
after 10 years of
conversations hitting a wall that
involved one person
maybe
you know under normal circumstances
yourself and joelle would have at least
kept royce in the loop
but at a certain point in time
when the frustration is at a
a level where it's like you know what we
know we've we've done this over and over
and over
we just got to do what we got to do it
just is what it is like it just is what
it is at this point and it's like you
know
um
i was in my kitchen right we were
talking me and royce and joelle
and i said royce if joe ain't gonna rap
because he's not gonna rap i didn't even
believe joe a rap yeah i'm like yo
[Music]
are you down to do the three-man crew
don't say that crook don't put that in
the universe um he's gonna he's gonna be
he's gonna do do the right thing
so we keep talking for 15 20 minutes and
we're about to hang up the phone i said
listen race i just really need to hear
this
i know you said don't put it in the
universe i'm not trying to put any
negativity no negative vibes out there
but if joe isn't with this
are you gonna do the three-man crew
and he's like
slaughterhouse is four people so what is
what do you think that means kev that
means no it means no
without saying no that means no he's
slaughterhouses four people so
technically neither of you are lying
because
technically well i didn't say no well
i'm gonna tell you let's like this
i'm
joelle
was like no no crook he did say
slaughterhouses not four people but i
was on the call he said no okay and i
was like
i was just so
clouded and my mind got clouded when he
said that because it meant so much to me
that
when he said
slaughterhouses four people and i'm like
yo
this is over
so i kind of blacked out on the phone
like
all this [ __ ] work that i put in all
this [ __ ] that we built together this
[ __ ] is really over
was there ever an idea to replace joe
um
people always say hey won't you replace
joe um you know won't you put m in that
slot let him what was the other guy who
was supposed to be part of the group was
it nino blessed was that his name nino
bliss i remember he was like on that
first slaughterhouse record that was
like not even a slaughterhouse right
yeah shout out nino bless you know i
mean like he's very instrumental into
how this whole thing came together he's
part of the story
you know what i mean and i just think
that
you know everybody who was part of the
story needs a mention now you know so
how about this like i know you and royce
better than i know joelle and joe i know
you guys to be men of high integrity
high character
you guys have have the longevity you've
had in this industry for a reason
um
never know [ __ ] involving y'all's
names right um
you know i can understand the
frustration of royce's side saying hey
that's that's our logo that you guys are
putting on the front of that and you
guys just
bombard us with this album that i had no
idea was coming right and it's our logo
on fire
you know he has a to me he has he has a
right to be emotional about that and to
feel a way about that would you agree
um absolutely
and and like you guys obviously know
that like you said you said you said i i
can give i i knew that this i didn't
give them a heads up so i understood
that they they're that there's going to
be an emotional reaction right and you
kind of accounted for that already right
no i i i give them room to react to that
you know what i'm saying um
you know i'm watching how i'm watching
the reactions you know what i'm saying
because
if it was me
you know but i feel differently but if
it was me i'm i don't care they can use
the slaughterhouse logo for whatever
they want to use it for you know what i
mean like i said who owns that logo well
what happened was they're saying that
ownership was
relinquished to the group later i
haven't seen no paperwork stating that
um
we got jerked in the beginning you know
somebody
um
owned it that was not a part of the
group
you feel me so somebody on the
management team owned it
to my knowledge
someone who was a part of the group's
management groups management okay you
know what i mean so
um right off rip that should have been
that that's that's a red flag but i
heard that they made it right and
relinquished it to the group when we
went to shady i'm not sure i've never
seen the paperwork on that when i go and
look look up the trademark i don't see
our names anywhere mentioned on the
trademark so i i don't know who owns it
and if they really feel some type of way
somebody would just sue you yeah and i
would just
take it off the cover and keep going
yeah you know what i'm saying because
this story is going to be told they
can't stop it they can't you know i feel
like they have efforts to try to
do damage control over something that
they haven't even heard yet you know
what i mean and it's like
um
you know
this story needs to be told for us
on our fans
i think the fans need closure and i
think y'all need clothes i need hella
closure kev i'm gonna tell you because
guess what every [ __ ] time you do an
interview or joelle does an interview or
royce does an interview or
everyone's asking what's up with what's
up with glasshouse what's up with
slaughterhouses it'll never go away
until you just close the chapter and say
burn the book you have to
and that's what i had to do man like a
lot of people like you burning the
shirts up on the video no listen
i'm trying to get this low vibration
[ __ ] out of my life forever i'm in a
whole another place i'm six years sober
i haven't i've been you know in master
classes i've been you know trying to
better myself get to get myself into a
better headspace just be a better human
being period i need this negative
triggering [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of my life
for forever i don't want to go back to
it they could do whatever they want with
it and that was my that was my intention
so just
me symbolically
tearing slaughterhouse down out of my
life you know i'm saying me personally
if they want to uphold it and they want
to put it on a pedestal they could do
that all day and i'm they're not going
to hear a peep for me you know what i
mean but me personally i had to get it
out of my life because every single time
we spoke about it talked about it tried
to do it again and it didn't happen and
all the interviews and then post a
[ __ ] piece of toast on instagram and
people still like yo what's up that
toast is cool but what's up with
slaughterhouse you know it's just too
much man
i'm over it it needs to go you know what
i'm saying i mean listen i respect it
man hey we got to stop the interview
real quick man shout out to our sponsors
at my bookie now if you're into sports
like me you like to win money
what are we doing go to my bookie right
now man let's get in on some of this
action
my bookie go sign up get the double
deposit bonus this is what this means
when you sign up in my bookie right now
all right whatever money you would
deposit they're gonna match it they're
gonna double it for you up to a thousand
dollars but you gotta use the keyword
the promo code bootleg that's right use
that promo code bootleg when you sign up
at my bookie they're going to double
your deposit listen march madness is
coming up
my favorite time of the year to gamble
is march madness it is so much fun you
don't got to know a [ __ ] thing about
college basketball it is just [ __ ]
turnt up i love to go to
listen march madness that's really all
you need to know get your account before
then thank me later also nba action is
finally back throw down some futures who
do you think is going to win the mvp
joel embiid jokic devin booker a little
dark horse you know i'm saying shout out
to the suns uh you got to go to my
bookie though sign up get down right now
all right get double your money double
your deposit you put in a thousand
they're gonna match that give you a
whole nother thousand to gamble with
mybookie.ag
use the promo code bootleg double your
deposit i respect it i think um i mean
like i said i understand everyone's kind
of side
i think that
you know
the one thing i saw i just saw rory did
you see rory and maul and what they did
so they they kind of talked about what's
going on in their podcast right and
uh maul was like
now [ __ ] that they they can they they
should be able to do that album like you
know what i'm saying and the one thing
that like they said and i know that
they're
probably closer to
the situation than a lot of people are
right absolutely especially mom
you guys weren't friends is what they
said them them guys ain't friends
they they were in a group together that
don't mean that they're friends
yeah i was friends with it was i it was
odd i was friends with joe uh joelle and
royce you know what i'm saying royce was
friends with me and joe
you know i was saying
joelle was frizz with me and royce and
then some happened to that dynamic
between him and royce so it's just like
me and joelle was friends it was just
really really really odd man and it's
just it might be the oddest concoction
for an actual group that toured together
that put albums out together in terms of
like
how it was formed right there was really
no you guys never had a real origin
story it's not like you guys grew up
together
we think of griselda we think of wu-tang
all these people grew up together so
you know the
downfalls of those groups were it was a
lot of emotional family based [ __ ] with
you guys it was
listen man the fans wanted this we did
it
would you say you start because i think
like um
i always talk to groups uh there's a
group out of la uh called shoreline
mafia yeah sholai mafia shout out to uh
ogeezy uh and he had said that like when
they did their first tour together
he started to kind of notice the cracks
in the foundation because they had to be
around each other a lot right
your guys's first tour was at the tech
nine tour i think that was our first big
tour yeah did you notice back then just
being on the road together that there
was that there was some red flags well
when i first we first did our um thing
at best buy
and i don't want listen i'm not here to
assassinate joe character so i'm i'm
gonna get off joe you know what i'm
saying i'ma just say this
we did uh when we did our uh
our first in store at best buy on the
east coast
you know um somebody told me
whatever you do
don't let joe be joe
and i didn't know what that meant
because we were
relatively brand new
to each other you know i didn't know
what that meant you know but i found out
you see what i'm saying rather quickly
yeah rather quickly and and you just got
people who have two different types of
vibes two different types of mindsets
two different types of you know what
their moral compass is and things of
that nature it's just you know it is
what it is so it was very hard for us to
to even you know rock like that and
it was almost like a lot of times dawg i
stayed
i stayed
silent
because i had love for royce
you know what i mean so a lot of times
i was like yo i'm a chill
because i had love for race and i
understood that royce had a different
relationship with joe but royce knew
because sometimes i was like yo this
dude is this dude wilding right now you
know what i mean and me and him i have a
conversation it's it's
royce was really the glue he was the
glue for between that
between joe and the rest of the group
yeah
yeah i mean and and the thing is now
don't get me wrong joe brings a lot to
the table of course he's i mean he's an
all-time great emcee as well yeah he's
joe's in his bag he's one of them ones
he's one of them one so he bring he
brings up he brings all that to the
table you know what i mean but
you know um
that's dope from a fan perspective but
when you have to be inside a group with
someone you have to be doing business
you have to do business with somebody
you have to be you know share the same
quarters with somebody is different you
know what i mean and and uh
it wasn't going to work it was it just
wasn't going to work so where did you
like at what point in time did you reach
your break because you had said earlier
that you had already you had already
reached your breaking point with joe but
you would kind of
okay i'm going to give it one more go
when did you initially reach that
breaking point with joe well
royce
wanted everybody to come to heaven and
detroit his studio
and do
some joints for glass house and
um um
we all
scheduled it
said i will be there
you know this was some years ago too
and
i flew out there
and i was the only one that showed up
wow
you see i'm saying
and
i'm like where what's going on where's
everybody out so i called joelle where
you at
and he's like oh crook man you down
there i should have called you before
you jumped on the plane joe told me he
wasn't going so i just i didn't get on
the plane i figure if he's not going
well it's a waste of time
and i said but why did he say that and
he was like he's like i don't know he
just said he wasn't going
at the last minute and i was like wow so
now here i am in detroit it's it's
snowing like a [ __ ] it's cold as
[ __ ] and i'm standing outside smoking a
[ __ ] cigar with [ __ ] snowflakes on
my beard and [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] am
i gonna do now so me and royce ended up
doing like nine or ten joints ourselves
just
using the time to create you know what i
mean as long as we might not ever hear
songs you might not never hear you know
what i mean and uh
that was it for me on my plane ride back
i was like you know what i'm never doing
this
i'm not doing this
with that type of energy and
i was only willing like i said
for royce and
funny enough
you know i know i know how royce feels
i'm very considerate of other people's
feelings
but sometimes you got to consider your
own feelings
and it was time for me to shut down shop
and and move on
yeah i think like i said like i
understand the perspective of like
joe and roy saying hey that's our logo
slaughterhouse is ours too right you're
kind of putting out this album kind of
you know telling his story telling our
story for us and also using i'm telling
you using the group's imagery using i'm
not telling this story kind of using
slaughterhouse as like the focal point
of this project so i understand their
perspective like in my like like i'm
sure if i had a [ __ ]
of the bootleg head podcast and my
producer cook started a podcast
talking about the behind the scenes and
it was like my name my my logo xed out
i'd be like yo what the [ __ ] but it
wasn't maybe there was no disrespect
intended
but i could understand that perspective
but on the other hand it's like
if you guys knew like look [ __ ] it
whatever happens happens we're lighting
this [ __ ] on fire and i need this [ __ ]
off of me i gotta get this [ __ ] off me
it's like both i think both sides okay
so tell me this if you do a documentary
on michael jordan
scottie pippen is going to be in that
[ __ ]
true and i think it's kind of a similar
thing to where you think of like
how scottie pippen got mad about the
last dance yeah so i i understand why he
was mad because he didn't really get to
fully
explain what happened so that's when
scottie pippen goes and makes his last
dance
joe royce go
musically go talk to the fans right dude
do whatever you want maybe that's what
their ig live was yeah nah man that's
not gonna work it's it's it's it's art
overlap over live uh over lives it's art
over ig lives bro what did you think of
the ig live in in terms of because a lot
of people were making
i think a lot of people took some of
this stuff out of context in terms of
the headlines i saw right like joe
saying uh that album can suck my dick
some people were like yo he told joel
ortiz to suck his dick yeah well yeah
even though he said the album i just
feel like that's going too far you know
what i'm saying like there's certain
[ __ ] you just don't do but you know um
what i think of it i wanted to get in
there i laughed i think it would have
landed i'm in there pressing requests
let me in
different conversation yeah it would
have been a different conversation
because at that point they were saying
that there was no deal and then i could
have probably got them to admit that
there was a deal and that point they
were saying they never said no and then
you know later on joe did an interview
with one of the guys who i watch all the
time on psa hip-hop um and he said you
know it all boiled down to
crook wanted to do a deal that joe
didn't want to do you know joe didn't
want to do the deal so
he did say no he's admitting now that
you know i mean he didn't want to do the
deal and we it got caught up in
semantics like i never said no there was
never a deal that's what it felt like it
felt like semantics
you know there was a deal you know you
didn't want to do the deal let's get
past that because we can't find common
ground if we don't start off with
honesty and truth you know we got to
start at honesty and truth and then try
to find common ground if you're going to
say you know there was no deal where's
the paper of course there was no paper
because i said have joe hit me and he
never [ __ ] hit me so how can i even
put his desires for the deal in
paperwork for him if he's not even going
to call me he's not even going to give
me that information so it's it's
impossible when was uh the official
release of of you guys as a group from
shady it was a over a year ago over a
year ago yeah and again who did we do
that for
for joe right
i mean because really i feel like when
joe was on everyday struggle talking
about eminem a lot obviously yeah some
of the things he said i didn't
necessarily disagree with right okay but
you know
but if you're joe budden and you're
signed to your group signed to the label
you you might want to make the business
decision to just kind of hold hold back
a little you know what i'm saying but
especially if if your brother royce
is it's over there trying you know to
hold it together
i was over there too but let's just put
it on race if royce was over there
trying to
he was
trying to put
glass house out under the shady umbrella
the same day when joe was throwing those
grenades at everything
he was working during that time period
to try to get glass house out do you
think joe knew that probably
because if he knew that and i know he
probably knew it
you know what i'm saying he probably
knew it he wanted off shady let me know
if i'm wrong glass house was supposed to
be
executive produced by jess blaze or was
it executive produced by just blaze and
we kind of like formulated this
slaughterhouse of producers of all
amazing producers you know justice
league
ill mind cardiac was there you know um
man who else was in there
it was
it was crazy to see them all making
beats together like
it was just it was amazing
i don't know if any of those songs
leaked
some of the songs we've played pieces
bits and pieces and things like that but
for the most part there's a whole album
that nobody really ever heard
you know what i'm saying and it was easy
to finish we had like you had enough
joints to
you could go into what we recorded and
create an album out of that you know
what i'm saying um hopefully uh somebody
conveniently leaks that [ __ ] online well
i i thought about the leak man but it's
like you know those producers worked
hard they didn't get paid you know what
i'm saying and i'm sure a lot of those
producers wouldn't mind well if they
could if they yeah if the producers are
on board then absolutely
but you know we don't want to we don't
want to harm anybody business-wise you
know because one of the beasts went to
ross
you know what i mean which raspy um the
song is called
i forgot this is just blaze ross raw
song okay you know what i'm saying so it
went one of the beasts went to ross so
you know um
if those producers could still find a
way to to eat off those beats i would
just say someone conveniently who has
access to the album give it to someone
else who just conveniently leaks it
anonymously online and then it's on
reddit and then you know the people who
want to hear it can hear it
hey it might leak tonight they might try
to they might try to leave they might
try to leak it before me and joelle
should drop
hey that's some real [ __ ]
i could see that so they could change
the subject and [ __ ] yo man you can't
change the subject the fans want closure
bro i talk to them every single day on
twitter now you're super active
want closure bro they want to know why
how you know if we put the fans are the
fifth member of slaughterhouse if we
ever put them first class house would
have came out everybody put ego and
pride first
that's why glasshouse never came out
it's that simple like if you had to
really it sounds like
and again
it sounds like if it weren't for joe
budden the album would have been out
hey dawg am i crazy yo listen joe
retired
he said it on his podcast no i they can
go and do whatever
i'm trying to tell you i think see royce
is a
a music he's a heavy heavy music guy so
in his mind he probably has this album
this this crazy album that he knows that
we can achieve as a as a group that he
wants to you know
help
he he wants to paint this picture he
just probably has so many ideas when it
comes to slaughterhouse that he wants to
do but what he doesn't understand is is
that
it's not going to get done bro yeah i
mean we've it's 10 years bro
i feel sad every time i see him talking
about he was gonna get joe to rap i'm
like dude he was never gonna rap i mean
listen royce is one of the greatest of
all time yes absolutely i think when
you're royce and you
put out i mean the book of ryan and alex
got nominated for rap album of the year
probably the two best bodies of work of
his career absolutely
i'm not sure like if you're royce like
the headache or the it's just a lot like
it sounds like the whole slaughterhouse
thing is a lot
it is and
anything when there's four moving parts
four new four people ever you got a
manager yeah he's got a manager he's got
a manager we all got four lawyers it's
just it's a lot and if and you know for
me like i just had always assumed this
[ __ ] was a rap forever when joe retired
right i was just like oh well now see
you assume that yeah well now you you're
like no we're gonna put an album out and
let you know it's a wrap yeah yeah i
mean because because there's your guys's
fans are a certain type of
cult
following where they're they're until
they get the final no they're going to
keep harping on the situation they're
very invested in to slaughterhouse they
are very invested you know what i'm
saying and i don't think in this whole
debacle nobody is
nobody's caring about i mean i even
heard joe say the fans are idiots i'm
like dog listen
um
when we was on tour
i'm the last man on the tour bus
first man off
i'm out there with the fans we get off
the stage i'm taking pictures with them
i'm signing autographs i'm doing shots
with the fans we talking rap you know
what i'm saying that's just who i am
these are the people who love what we
love these are the people who put us
where we are you know what i mean and
i'm out there showing love having fun
with the fans at all times so i've
always been that type of person and it
doesn't stop because slaughterhouse
stops you know what i'm saying so when
the fans hit me and they're like yo you
we you know i was listening to your song
goodbye and you know my uncle died of
cancer too and man it just really it
saved me from wanting to harm myself and
just know that you're going through the
same thing and all that i take that [ __ ]
to heart that [ __ ] ain't just a comment
on my [ __ ] on my screen that's
[ __ ] real [ __ ] and i take that [ __ ]
to heart and when they tell me they want
to know what the [ __ ] is going on with
the music and why we ain't putting out
no records and what happened to
slaughterhouse i want to give them that
closure too look this is what happened
now i'm not going to go super deep and
dig up all kind of [ __ ] and show you
where the bodies are i'm just going to
be like yo this is what happened and you
know thank you for all your support over
the [ __ ] years i'm sorry to be the
bad news bad news i'm sorry to be that
guy but this is what the [ __ ] happened
it's over and some of the best
[ __ ] movies are based on a true
story this is a true story period wait
hold on time to stop the interview
because we gotta talk about our good
folks at odd socks man listen if you go
to
oddssoxofficial.com that's odd
soxofficial.com use the keyword keyword
it's a [ __ ] promo code use the
[ __ ] promo code bootleg kev all right
at checkout you'll save 20 off they got
i mean look at these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg kev at check out save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them did joe
ever feel this type of way when you
started to do
crooks corner
uh and you're like your your platf likes
and by the way you're not doing that
anymore are you yeah the youtube channel
yeah are you still like because i feel
like i feel like you did did you slow
down a bit on doing it uh we started
doing because you were doing it starting
off dx for a while right i was doing it
with hip-hop dx and then um you know i
moved it to another to to my own channel
i got the eminem interview which is huge
you know um
my channel got taken deleted for some
some other stuff right so
um i started a brand new channel sat
through and you know i started a brand
new channel i have a brand new location
we we do crooks corner in a new location
now you know what i mean we got
it's a beautiful location um leased that
out for a year and um you know i've been
having guests coming in and out um
shoot man i don't have
all kind of people so yeah we still we
still doing it it's still rocking and
rolling the new channel is growing right
now you know what i mean i'm very happy
with where we are with crooks corner i
think my next episode is going to be
with ice tea he dropped some jewels you
know what i mean and iced tea yeah shout
out to iced tea he came in he killed it
um you know and uh
you know i had a millionaire on there he
was talking you know business oh he's
killing him i heard he's killing it on
the tech side on the tech side so it's
going now to answer your question
um i don't know how he felt but i had
clb radio before he started the joe
budden podcast i already had clb radio
me and dj ski had i remember you know
what i'm saying so i've always been in
this space
it's just that i've been juggling [ __ ]
you know i mean because i got a lot of
different ventures and businesses that
i'm a part of so it's like i have to
always juggle my time and [ __ ] but now
i'm planning to you know i'm in the
middle of making my retirement album so
once i get that retirement album done
i'll be able to focus on crooks corner
multimedia and we'll be able to just
start taking off so you're retiring next
yeah so you're done
yeah i mean i don't mind to come out to
play for a feature i'm not wondering
someone's out there i don't know what
i'm saying yeah but
making solo albums and you know
and that was another reason why this
album was so necessary to me man with me
and joelle because i want to say all the
things i need to say to the people
before i turn the mic off you know
that's such a large part of your legacy
man it's a large part this is you know
people like but why did you rap about
that listen i've been rapping about my
life my whole [ __ ] life
and this is something that happened in
my life that's why i don't get when
people are like hey but why are you
rapping about it oh when i left death
row records i rapped about it you know
what i'm saying i left shady records and
in slaughterhouse i'm rapping about it
i'm entitled to rap about it you know
what i mean that's what i've been doing
my whole [ __ ] life some some of my
fans know my life
better than people in my family would
you ever write a book
for sure because i feel like you're one
of the few artists that could say you
were a part of death row and shady
and then also just some of the walls you
broke down in terms of
when you were dropping a record every
week
that was something that you were the
first to do yes and then everybody
everybody i mean that blog era you were
early and like i remember like early
blog era [ __ ] and you were there with
the rights and the two dope boys
dropping a record every [ __ ] week yes
sir and then everybody else did it
everybody else did it and i think once
everybody else did it it ultimately
changed the way all fans digest music
it kind of if you think about it you're
kind of right because now
everyone we used to think
if i got an album from my favorite
artist every year and a half or two i'm
that's awesome i'm good yeah
so now your favorite artist got to be
super active because super active you
got it on your phone and yeah no that's
some real [ __ ] that's some real [ __ ] we
shifted the game with that so
yeah dawg i i'm down the right books you
know i i started on the book i had a st
actually
we have this mini series called
foreclosure me and joelle that's you
know that we're advertising
the album how we're rolling out the
album right and um that that actually
comes from a book title because i
actually wrote a book about
slaughterhouse
you wrote a whole book but i ain't
finished it but i got i got hella
chapters it's dope too it's it's really
dope it's a dope ass book man it talks
about you know
how it all was in the beginning and and
in the um the creative process it's just
really dope i just never i haven't
finished it but it was called
foreclosure you know what i'm saying so
this is something that's always been on
my mind like you know this is something
that i needed i needed to get out there
and you know i needed that therapy i
needed that medicine i needed group
therapy with the fans the ones who built
it with us i needed to tell them what
was going on and and hear feedback i'm
not always right yeah you know what i'm
saying i'm i'm open to the feedback but
you know just don't don't try to
don't try to assassinate my character by
saying that i'm lying about something
because i'm not lying about anything
every time i speak i want the truth to
come out
i'm not lying about nothing there's
nothing that i've said so far that's
false you know i'm saying i said that i
brought a deal to the table i did i said
that joe didn't want to do it he didn't
i said that royce didn't want to do the
three-man group he didn't want to do the
three-man group i haven't told one lie
yet i don't understand how they can call
me a liar does this album permanently
fracture your relationship with royce
um in my mind it shouldn't
but you know what i'm saying all i could
do is speak for myself i just think of
his ig post you know like what he said
in the ig post yeah that's what i'm
saying like it's like you know
in my mind no it shouldn't that's what
i'm saying in my mind it shouldn't you
know i mean because
um
i got love for royce
you know me and royce have similar
beliefs you know um
we live by similar code you know i'm
saying so it's like i got love for race
no doubt um
but this is something that had to happen
and
you know
if he wants to continue
to rap do business with joe
you know that's great you know and i'm
just saying yo bro i had to get off that
bus i can't i can't be on the bus no
more with that that's a wrap on that how
close
was the reunion on the west side gun
[ __ ] from hap like how close was that
actually going to transpire because it
seemed like everyone was like was
everyone on board to do that for for gun
like how close like like how far did
those
discussions get because i think if
there's anyone who embodies the energy
you guys had it's it's griselda right
now
well they said that they were going to
do it
um but it became one of those
slaughterhouse things
you know nobody nobody ended up turning
in what they had to turn in and um by
that i think i think gunn changed his
mind
or something and he ended up using the
same beat that we all got he used that
song with us for our armani caesar yeah
for our money caesar here him and our
monty caesar did a joint on there and
once that floated out i threw my verse
out as a freestyle and i told my fans
and supporters yo this was supposed this
was supposed to be the griselda joint
that we were all gonna do at
slaughterhouse but you know once again
as soon as they asked me to rap i rap
i'm i was i had a joint on there you
know what i'm saying and it was funny
when roy said that because my my fans
and supporters were in the comments like
dawg we been knowing that that [ __ ]
wasn't going to happen
you're pretty transparent with your
people i'm super transparent now now
that i'm on discord
on discord you got the discord yeah now
i'm on the discord it's lit yeah it's
lit i got the i got the chris corner
server over there and we we inside our
chat room talking all kind of [ __ ] to
each other you know what i mean like we
we talk about everything man and
and and that's i think that's what
separates me from you know um a lot of
people out here is that we're not we
don't we're on equal footing man with
people who support us man and some
people think they rap stars and [ __ ] and
they think they too good to talk to
people you know what i mean even too
good to return phone calls but i ain't
you're not that guy i ain't gonna do it
yeah i'm not that guy um
this album coming out
you're guys the second album together
just you and joelle is this uh
something you guys are going to continue
obviously the next if you guys do i'm
assuming not every album is going to be
based on rise and fall slaughter not at
all because the first one wasn't
um but is this something you guys are
going to keep on doing or just yeah i
think me and joel might make another one
i'm not sure i don't want to really you
know i don't know but um when we did the
first one the pandemic just hit
i was in new york we did it rest in
peace fred the god son he was like he
was in every session with us
and um the pandemic had just hit so
after we i came back home
it was very hard
to move around because the country this
was something new to us yeah yeah
early on it was impossible it was
impossible yeah so we couldn't really
roll the album out like we wanted to so
you know we took this opportunity to to
be able to really you know put our
vision out there and show people that
you know what we do i mean shout out to
my man herb to our true team our visual
our visual game ain't playing either for
sure you know what i'm saying so it's
like you know
we we have a great team you know in
place to do whatever we want to do if if
he wants to
we could do some more music you know if
not i feel it you know i mean but i'm
definitely after i'm finished with this
album working on the retirement yeah
after i'm done with that you know i'm
i'm transitioning man you know what i'm
saying i'm transitioning but i'ma leave
with a bang like
like this last album the first four
joints is just ridiculous so i'm like yo
i'm gonna make sure i get out of here
and say something the right way the
right way yes sir how's your uh current
relationship with m
oh that's good
you like i feel like if you have a
retirement album i feel like eminem kind
of has to be on there hey man come on
marshall man you know i'm getting out of
here baby
i'm just saying
it's gonna happen you know this is the
last time i talked to him about it he
was like man don't don't retire
because he ain't because he ain't you
know what i'm saying but i mean
and that dude has a hard job boy because
he's a word smith he got to go in there
every time and try to top that last one
you know i'm saying that that's
that's what he does though he's a gunner
somebody like russ who kind of
used this the same blueprint in terms of
like what you were doing in the early
blog days to kind of get on just
dropping a record every week
uh
reaches out to you get you on the chomp
ep the first one right stockholm
syndrome right um
what i mean because russ
i think what he's done with these two
chomp projects is like
pretty special because like
if you didn't know better you would be
very surprised to hear russ who's known
for his melodies and you know he'd be
saying some fly [ __ ] popping his [ __ ]
but he's really
throwing punches with the best of the
best on these two projects what was that
like like him reaching out to you did he
just slide you in like the dm or yeah he
just hit me on he just hit me online
because you know we always in the
trenches he see me and a lot of times
his name used to pop up in my timeline
people be like yo what do you think of
russ or this and i'm like yo i like russ
you know russ is out there doing his
independent thing you know he's giving
jewels to up-and-coming artists lots of
lots of jewelry i [ __ ] with russ so you
know he hit me up and he's like would i
do it i was like [ __ ] that's nothing you
know what i mean sent it back to him
he's like yo you killed that [ __ ] i was
like you're looking bro it's all good
you know
it's real easy i'm very easy to work
with and um i like i like that kind of
environment i like that people who are
easy to work with i like to be in good
creative environments where there's not
a lot of you know head button and
channel some people like that because
that's sometimes that brings out some of
the best music you know
super challenges and adversity and all
that type of [ __ ] but i don't like that
i like a good workflow you know what i'm
saying i had that as a as a [ __ ] kid
i've been in the game a long time you've
been in the game
i'm too old for all that [ __ ] now i like
the google environment you know just out
of beanbag over here you chilling you
sipping lemonade over there yo pull the
beetle i cool let's get it cracking none
of that other [ __ ] um before you we get
out of here obviously the album by the
time this comes out the album will be
out yeah go get the album yes go run it
up run it up um i'm sure is there going
to be merch there's merch available you
know the merch the pre-orders is looking
nice you know what i'm saying run up the
merge run that up uh maybe a book coming
soon
album retirement album what's up with
horseshoe gang yo the shoe gang man like
em he really loved him too
and um you know uh
is everyone in horseshoe gang related to
you yeah that's my little brothers okay
yeah yeah they look they they masters
that what they're doing
and um you know they're starting to turn
the corner a lot of people are giving
them props other people want to work
with them you know um some super
producers want to work with them now so
we we in the mix with that right now
also shout out to uh i want to shout out
razz cass's sons because they're in a
group called
post contra yeah they're dope i'm trying
to get them on the show they uh they've
been opening up on the court day tour
yeah
they're [ __ ] crazy
shout out to those guys
i just saw one of their freestyles pop
up on my [ __ ] and i was like oh my god
who are these kids yeah yeah them kids
don't i didn't even know i'd reached out
dm'd and then like i saw razz like
repost them and i was like oh [ __ ] those
are his sons the twins are his boys
as [ __ ] like that [ __ ] that's crazy i
love it hey listen man hip hop is is
aging so we're able to see things we've
never seen before 100 percent you know i
mean it's a new it's it's a new genre of
music relatively new so we've never got
to see yeah the lineage
we had chris rivers sitting right here
like a couple weeks ago and
man that [ __ ] went crazy yeah
that's what i'm saying chris rivers you
know i mean like yo it's just it's dope
to see the growth man everything is dope
but yeah well look man i appreciate you
pulling up and giving us some context on
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah man you
know they throwing darts at me kev you
know what i'm saying i had to come in
and set the record straight real quick
yeah listen i think it's just important
to get
all of the context
you know to get as much of
your side of what's going on and um you
know i think that that was a big thing
that was missed about you know some of
the headlines that were made off of that
ig live was you really weren't able to
speak i wasn't able to speak you know i
tried to get in there so i did my own
life you know what i mean
and you know i talked to the people
myself but you know it's all good like
like i said dog it's just getting it out
there the story is out there
um the fans are getting closure leave
the slaughterhouse questions behind
after this sentence
just go press play for all the [ __ ]
questions that's all y'all got to do man
and you be all right with me you know me
there it is man king crook crooked i
appreciate you pulling up thanks for
having me hey shout out your youtube
channel that you that you know brooks
corner come to crook's corner come mess
with me man we got a lot of content over
there it's beautiful boom